this is what little remains of the
ruined bridge in India's Northern Bihar
state
[Music]
Monday a 200 meter person collapsed into
the Gandhi's River
several construction workers were on the
bridge at the time
a search and rescue operation is
underway
we felt heavy Tremors and it felt like
there was a blast later we found out
that the bridge collapsed and this tells
us that the government is corrupt no
attention was paid towards its
construction
company is building the bridge at a cost
of more than 200 million dollars
construction began in 2014
but people who live nearby say the
project has been marred by a series of
errors
it was supposed to be completed four
years ago but that deadline has been
extended four times and this is the
second time in more than a year part of
the bridge has collapsed at least one
person is missing
we have conducted an investigation and
have reported the findings to the head
of the District administration we've
received instructions to monitor the
area all night so I immediately sent for
the national disaster rescue Force teams
who covered the entire area since it was
difficult to deploy such and rescue
boats at night I have sent them at the
break of dawn once completed the bridge
is expected to connect trade and
commuters from the city of iguani to the
town of Sultan gange in Bihar state but
people who live in the area are
skeptical saying after years of
mismanagement the bridge may never be
completed at all
ah Al Jazeera